question is do you want to be a wife yes
and if so
what makes a good wife so starting here
and I go wow
what makes a good wife
um I think companionship like definitely
friendship I think that's a big thing in
a marriage
um I wouldn't know that because I'm not
married but you know it's something I
want is to be literally my partner's
best friend
um
do you think men want a best friend yeah
100 100 okay yeah really
men want to talk to women all the time
okay yeah not all the time
yeah even me it's not all the time but
okay okay anything else
um
just just to be there just show up okay
yeah women don't have to do anything but
be a best friend and show up to be a
wife okay not just that okay
so I'm just gonna go off of what you say
so
um
just I I don't know okay I just um
because we live in this in a society
like this in terms of like cooking and
like traditional things I've I don't
even feel like it should be like you
know divide should be half yeah divided
definitely so I don't think it's like a
compulsory thing do you think all the
like fixing stuff around the house
should be divided half half
um
I mean if you can do that so the dates
be half I'm just I'm just you know we're
gonna this is the energy right yeah and
that would be a good wife yeah I'll
split the chores with you I'll be your
best friend yes okay okay go ahead
um what do I think a why would you want
to be a wife and what makes a good wife
yeah I do want to be a wife
um I would say what makes a good wife is
being the type of woman that can
motivate and inspire a man to be the
best version of himself because I feel
like with a good woman by his side
supporting him a man can do incredible
things and I some I feel like some men
are lacking
that in their lives like they're like
they don't have that woman that's there
guiding them and like being supportive
and motivating him and lifting him up
um so how would a girl do that
just inspiring a man to be the best
version of himself like
um how
so like if I said I wanna I wanna I
wanna be a good wife and I'm coming to
you how can I inspire
well I feel like you you have to be a
good woman yourself first like you have
to be
like you have to be basically having
your own things like you have to be
independent you have to be like cultured
worldly intellectual
um you have to have things that also
Inspire the man and I feel like when you
have those things as a woman you can
bring those into the relationship and
the man sees you he sees your worth he
sees your value and he's like I've got
to set my game up like I've got to be
the best man for her
um because you inspire him to be like
that you know and where did you learn
this is this from your parents or did
you learn it somewhere else
yeah I did I think my mum really helped
my dad become the best version of
himself she helped him on the straight
road she made him cut out a lot of toxic
how did you do that
um because of her morals like she had
real strong morals he saw her value he
saw what type of woman she was and he
wanted to lock it down straight away he
was like this is like a real good woman
like she's you know there for me she's
supporting me she's trying to help me
build she wants to help me build this
Empire so I've got to get my act
together so yeah I did watch my mom and
dad like that because my question is
more you said independent and I just
when in history have Independent Women
have men wanted Independent Women
like what men have always wanted women
yeah that relied on them when I'm when
I'm in sorry I just want to rephrase
that when I meant independent I meant as
in like she is able to stand on her own
two feet like she doesn't need him she's
not constantly needing him she doesn't
give off that like needy clinginess like
she can do things around on her own but
she would rather let the man do things
for her if that makes sense but if he
wasn't around and God forbid something
happened then she'd be able to stand on
her own two feet because I feel like men
do want that they don't want to know
that you like
constantly like need them emotionally
mentally everything I've never heard a
guy say that he doesn't want a girl that
needs him but there's so many guys that
get turned off by it you know if they
don't like you if like usually it's like
a girl that's like a little bit too ugly
for him like typically like she's a
little bit below his typical league and
like that's why she's annoying to him
because she's not in his like
League
yeah like have you ever said a guy that
was into a girl that's like oh she's too
needy to me she wants me too much
I mean I have heard men say that but I
guess maybe they're with the wrong woman
I guess I don't know okay okay what do
you think well I think the woman needs
to look after the house I think she have
to
um be there for him like to support him
and I think the friendship is important
as well
um I don't know the respect as well
okay so you think she should take care
of the house she's respectful to him
yeah friendship I think that's important
okay they can be friends they can do
things together they can even house
things they can do together okay all
right go ahead it's a weird one for me
well do you want to be a wife and did
you say do you want you want to do it
well it's a tricky one for me because I
actually was a wife okay uh but now I'm
single so yeah I want to be a wife okay
okay all right sorry I just love love I
love love I love um
I kind of like the idea of
being a wife equaling things if that
makes sense like paying for dates
supporting our family supporting our
house when it comes to building stuff I
don't think so I like it though
um so you'll have the money yeah you'll
do 50 50 on the money but again I I
understand it comes to some extents
obviously we get pregnant we
um leave obviously because we are with
child
um
so I like the way you said that yeah
what's your question actually what makes
a good what makes a good wife makes a
good wife morals morals and I think
would you include like loyalty in that
absolutely okay so you'd say a woman's a
bad wife if she leaves no right no I I
did not disagree yeah but then how are
you a good wife if you leave
well if you don't have the reason to
stay you you have to leave you know
commitment vows
I think like
um to be married and to have a family
like I think that's beautiful and it can
be beautiful
um it's it's a commitment and it's hard
I feel like a lot of people
don't like to go through the hardship
but the hardship makes you stronger but
the good wives go through the hardship
and the bad wives leave no
I was asking her but you can ah sorry
um
think about that one I'm just I'm trying
to I'm trying to understand I don't know
like this someone just think if you're
good at something you get it done yeah I
feel like
um
it goes down to like being a team
you know and like working on things
together and progressing the
relationship together you know so if
someone's slacking
fair enough and if it is a long period
of time or it does affect the
relationship or you know
then you gotta cut it basically all
right all right what do you think makes
it good actually I'm gonna do the girls
first and then okay yeah so what do you
think do you want to be a wife and what
makes a good wife I'm gonna be
controversial and saying not really
don't want to be away no I only want I
would only get married if it was
something that the other person felt
really strongly about but to me
if you're in a relationship and you're
that committed to that person what what
is a marriage gonna do like what is that
commitment saying to other people
exactly and if I'm not committed to
someone that I feel like I should be
married to them
unless I believe in the religious
beliefs behind it
I just don't see it as being a bigger
progression in the commitment I should
be committed regardless okay and there
shouldn't be something on paper at a
state that I have to be that way it
should just be a mutual agreement that
you're both just a feeling committed and
committed and nothing's going to change
about that so personally it's not
something that I like
will ever try to force on someone or
something that I really want but if they
feel very passionately about it and I
feel like it's the right time I'm okay
with that okay and it's just something I
don't feel like what do you what do you
think makes a good wife
so
in all honesty I think just being there
as the other half
like I know you discussed about it I'm
just being complete them basically yeah
I know you discussed it as being like
you know a woman has a role in a
relationship but I'm actually bisexual
so to me it could work either way okay
and to me I feel like 50 50 is where
that kind of stuff needs to fall into
place 50 50 on everything because not
necessarily it give and take okay so if
you have to look at the person's
attributes what they give to a
relationship and break it down that way
I don't think it's a one size fits all I
don't think everyone can say right
you're gonna do this you're going to do
that because you're the man the man can
be [__] he could be really bad at it you
could be amazing at it yeah perfect let
them work to their strengths I think
that's what works in a relationship when
you let the other person working
together yeah sure but I think there are
some things that regardless whether
you're traditional or not there are some
things that naturally a mom might be
better a woman might be better at we're
very different biologically so there's
always going to be things that a man's
going to be slightly better at than a
woman unless they're you're an anomaly
and you're going to be 10 times stronger
than the man that's unlikely so I I
think yeah give or take it I think
everything has to be looked at
retrospectively and it has to be broken
down about each person's attributes and
what they can give to the situation so
what do you think makes a woman a good
wife
like what's just specific this is just a
bit broad so I'm just trying to kind of
Reign it in you know fair enough
um so being able to provide in a sense
that you can provide emotionally whether
you can provide financially is
irrelevant if the other person can
provide financially perfect you then
need to make up for the other gaps so as
a wife you might need to be able to be
able to look after children or be able
to look after man or the man be able to
look after you and you be receiving to
that because I think a lot of women
nowadays look at a relationship and
think the man should have to meet the
first of everything do everything but
that makes a lot of men very not a lot
of men but nowadays it makes them quite
intimidated and then they get nervous
and then they think oh what if I can't
do that you have to be receptive to what
they want to do if they want to buy Fufu
let them if they want to take you out on
a date and they want to pay for
everything I'm asking what does she have
to do she has to be receptive yeah
receive what else does she have to do
[Music]
um
again see because it's something that I
personally you don't yeah I don't know
it's something that I wouldn't really
have values on so I don't really think
what I'm gonna say is going to give you
much much information to be honest okay
no worries all right so question do you
want to be a husband
do I want to be a husband
um I am not enthusiastic about it with
the way that marriage is with laws and
just with the way the culture is in
general
um and I've been that way for a long
time I mean like as it was my parents
divorce when I was a kid so I never
really had a great argument uh you know
great example for sort of marriage and
and that kind of thing anyway and
obviously as time's gone on you know
we've seen what's happened in terms of
the way that Society is here in the USA
and Canada and Australia you know those
Western countries it's it's it's not a
good deal to be honest it's never been
something that I've been particularly
keen on I've become less keen on the
idea as I've gone on really now in a
sense I agree with what you said because
I think a long-term relationship fine
commitment fine do you want to put a
ring on it
probably not you know it would have to
be a very good reason for doing it or do
it somewhere else like do it over in um
maybe one of the Lesser you know Latin
American countries or something like
that okay and um out of what did you
hear about who did I marry no no
okay
what did you hear today was there
anything you heard that you thought yes
that would make a good way
I think a lot of the women were
a bit light on specifics to to be honest
you know there's a lot of stuff yeah
support and blah blah blah but there's
there's a lot there wasn't much
specifics in terms of what what is the
woman actually going to bring to the
table so
um I would say that but I mean I I think
really you want somebody who is
gonna support you he's gonna be easy to
be around you know
um and I think marriage worked pretty
well back in the day when things were
more traditional to be honest and I
think now we've come away from that it
just doesn't work as well you know and
um we're seeing that and you know as we
know the majority of divorces are caused
by women you know 70 of divorces are
initiated by women so it's women who are
women which is why modern women are
shitty wives exactly exactly but that's
another reason another reason I'm not
keen to go into it because for guys it's
a bit of a bad deal because you know the
women are very keen to get married you
know women will try to push the agenda
of like oh you know where are we are we
going to get engaged are we moving in
together we're gonna get married
but then they get fed up you know 10 10
15 years like down the line and they
initiate divorce and then the guy's
screwed so but why is she fed up why is
she fed up I well I think I mean there's
going to be many different reasons for
that and we could go into lots of
different examples but I think a lot of
it is that they lose the the you know
the butterflies go because and it's
inevitably gonna go over a longer period
of time because we all know you have
that honeymoon period and then you know
it gets always yeah yeah then it gets it
gets a bit boring and the problem with
that is that if you're then putting that
into a legal contract where one of the
parties could just say I'll sod that and
walk out that's a Dangerous Ground I
think no like I've got I don't know like
I've just got a thought
like obviously you said woman leave in a
marriage of course which I understand
but
I'm 21 like I know I'm still young but I
feel like there's a specific time period
to have kids
and to marry and settle down and I feel
like I don't know like this little
pressure because if I put myself in a
guy's
perspective of shoes like I'm not
bearing a child and that changes your
body it does it changes yeah we are of
course we have the biological clock
where we're all aware of it so yeah it's
harder for us I think that's why
probably why we want to lock it down oh
yeah yeah sure sure as many of you know
I was just banned on Tick Tock and we
are demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible